نحن الان في منطقه كهرمان مرش في منطقه
الوسط لهذه المدينه المنكوبه وهذا المجمع
السكني المدمر بالكامل الزوايا التي
يظهرها الصوره في الدرون هذا الكاميرا
الخاصه بالجزيره التي نحاول ان نعطيكم
فيها
زاويه كامله وصوره للمشهد بشكل اوسع لنعرف
حجم الدمار الذي حل بهذه المنطقه هذه
المنطقه التي تقع في وسط كهرباء
هي منطقه
مدمره بشكل شبهي كامل وحتى البنايات التي
نشاهدها في الصوره الان هي بنايات غير
صالحه للسكن هذه ما نشاهده في الصوره الان
هو
الملعب المدينه الذي زاره قبل
هذا اليوم الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
واطلع على احوال النازحين هذه الخيم هي
لنازحين الذين انتقلوا من العمارات
السكنيه الى الملعب المدينه حيث نصبت لهم
خيام هذه الصوره التي نشاهدها بشكل واسع
هي لاثار الدمار الذي اصاب هذا الجزء من
مدينه كهرمان مرعش ونشاهد فرق الانقاذ
تتواجد في اكثر من مكان واكثر زاويه تحاول
المساعده تحاول الوصول الى
ناجين تحت الانقاض وصلت فرق انقاذ من
اليابان من المانيا من اذربيجان وهناك فرق
انقاذ كما اخبرنا ستصل ايضا الى هذا
المكان للمساعده
اللقطه الواسعه التي تشاهدونها الان عبر
كاميرا الجزيره هي لقطه تعطي جزءا من
الدمار في المدينه الجزء الاكبر
يتوزع في مختلف احياء المدينه النازحون
هذا جزء هذا مخيم من بين مخيمات اخرى
مصيبه خارج حدود مدينه كهرمان مرعش معظم
هذه السيارات فيها عائلات تسكنها منذ
ثلاثه ايام ممن ليس لديه بدائل للسكن ولا
يستطيعون مغادره المدينه ممن لديهم ضحايا
لا يزالون في تحت الانقاض يريدون الوصول
الى اخبار اخبارهم او لعلهم يستطيعون
الوصول الى جثث ذويهم الذين توفوا تحت
الانقاض نحن في المتابعه ونعمل على مدار
الساعه كما تعمل فرق الانقاذ على ماده
الساعه لانقاذ اللاجئين لرصد جزء من
المشهد الماساوي الذي تعيشه هذه المدينه
وحالها حال بقيه المدن عبد العظيم محمد
الجزيره كهرمان مرش